President Trump is finally putting a
team in place that could begin to
address the grave and growing security
threats right here in our hemisphere the
corrupt narco-state in Venezuela the
explosion of coca in Colombia and the
attack on democratic institutions in
Central America by narco kingpins and
gangs they're even backing the election
of an anti-american candidate in Mexico
imagine another failed state like
Venezuela right on our doorstep a
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo can form
a diplomatic team of experienced and
loyal political pointings who can lead
and manage career diplomats to confront
threats rather than kick the can down
the road they should press for an urgent
transition in Venezuela rallying the
region to sanction the Maduro regime and
support democratic opposition and they
must help Colombia's next president
confront the persistent narco terrorist
threat and they should reassure Mexico
that the United States will be a
reliable partner growing together
economically and tending to common
security threats the new foreign policy
team must begin to take care of business
right here in our neighborhood what do
you think about President Trump's new
foreign policy team and US leadership
here in the Americas let us know in your
comments and also let us know if there
are other topics that you'd like
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI